tony abbott's appointment to a top trade
role
is seen by many as hugely controversial
and that's because of his views
mr abbott once said abortion was the
easy way out
that men were more adapted to authority
he also campaigned against same-sex
marriage
speaking before mr abbott was formally
announced as a member of the board of
trade
the prime minister chose his words
carefully
i obviously don't agree with those
sentiments
at all but then i don't agree with uh
everyone who serves
the government in an unpaid capacity on
on hundreds of
boards across uh the country and and i
can't be expected
uh to to do so this is a guy who was
elected by the people of the great
liberal democratic nation of australia
the board of trade will help britain
secure trade deals
after brexit as a former prime minister
of australia mr abbott has experience of
trade deals
but his controversial views made it a
hard sell for ministers
he's a homophobe and he's a misogynist
well uh he's also an expert in trade
so one plays off against the other
really is that really what you're saying
health secretary come on
well no what i'm saying is that we need
experts in uh
different areas
and misogyny by this man not now
not ever if he wants to know what
misogyny looks like in modern australia
he doesn't need a motion in the house of
representatives
he needs a mirror julia gillard another
former prime minister of australia
herself
said she stands by her actions i
certainly stand by
every word of that speech i doubt that
i'll ever be able to
put it better in my life than the things
that i said
that day on misogyny of course it's not
for me
to work out who should be the uk
trade envoy or specialist this is a
decision for the uk
government senior lgbt supporters
including the actor sir ian mcclellan
had written to the government urging
them to reconsider this appointment
an appeal that fell on deaf ears some
senior ministers had tried to urge the
government to reconsider mr abbott's
appointment
his critics believe he's not the right
person for the job
that his views matter others say he's
got experience
and he will help britain forge new trade
deals after brexit
in weighing up the argument the
government clearly believes that mr
abbott
is more of an asset than a liability
nick martin sky news